is a big announcement out of washington  the entertainer for this year's white  house correspondents dinner drum roll  please yes it will be  trevor noah  yeah host of the daily show wow  i know it's a pretty big deal that is a  big first of all we haven't had one  there hasn't been one in a couple of  years right correspondent dinner is set  this year for april 30th of course  trevor noah will also be the mc at the  64th annual grammys on april 3rd right  here on seabees on a roll maybe i should  ask for my grammy and the correspondence  dinner ticket i was gonna write you have  a grammy  what did you do  i want a seat to the grammys you don't  want a grammy statue trevor noah is very  funny he's also sometimes not very safe  he could be a little dangerous at that  white house correspondents meeting  there's a tradition of some pretty  on-the-nose jokes yes i'm looking  forward to it  it's been a while we need to get  together with our friends all right  across the dc landscape yeah